[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing a notorious
mass murderer fenrir greyback as well as
the events of the deathly hallows
more specifically we're going to be
discussing what happened to greyback
after the war was he punished let free
let's dive into it the most important
thing that you need to know about fenrir
greyback is that he was a lycanthrope
one who suffers from lycanthropy
the term lycanthrope refers to those who
are able to transform into a werewolf
whether willingly or by a curse with
that said
the life of a werewolf is said to be
cursed in and of itself
with a considerable amount of societal
stigma directed
the werewolf population when fenrir
himself was at one stage infected with
lycanthropy
he made it his mission to infect as many
people as possible
so that others could feel his plight as
he grew older he was able to rally his
fellow werewolves
and start a movement revolution with the
goal of bringing werewolves to power
however with that said in the second
wizarding war fenrir and the werewolves
ended up allying with voldemort
and the death eaters in the second
wizarding war voldemort saw an
opportunity with fenrir
a way to capitalize on his notoriety and
inside fear in the wizarding population
however despite being a valuable weapon
in voldemort's arsenal
fenrir was never granted death eater
status
and likely would have been disposed of
by voldemort later on in the event that
the death eaters won the war
i say this because voldemort did not
think highly of most magical beasts
stigma towards werewolves was not
exclusive to the good guys
okay so if voldemort and the bad guys
had won
then fenrir would have likely been
disposed of but
they didn't win the good guys did so
what came
of fenrir greyback what happened to him
after the battle of hogwarts
the first thing to point out is that
fenrir's fate could be interpreted
differently from book to film
in the film we last see fenrir in
deathly hallows part 2
when he's blasted by hermione's stunning
spell and sent flying off
to the ravine below presumably to his
death hermione fired the spell at him
after discovering him mauling lavender
brown however this scene from the film
actually contradicts the book as in the
book greyback shows up again later in
the battle
hermione did hit him with a blasting
curse but it never killed him
and probably didn't send him flying as
far as is shown in the film
no shriek tomani and with a deafening
blast from her wand
fenrir greyback was thrown backwards
from the feebly stirring body of
lavender brown
he hit the marble banisters and
struggled to return to his feet
then with a bright white flash and a
crack a crystal ball fell on top of his
head
and he crumpled to the ground and did
not move though it sounds as if this was
the end of greyback
chapter 36 reveals that this is in fact
not the case
as ultimately ron and neville were
responsible for taking down
the notorious werewolf harry saw ron and
neville bringing down fenrir greyback
aberforth stunning rookwood arthur and
percy
flooring thickness and lucius narcissa
malfoy running through the crowd
not even attempting to fight screaming
for their son
and this is the last we hear of him what
does brought down really mean
did ron and neville fire a killing curse
what did they do to him
in my opinion ron and neville would not
have killed him simply stunned him
which leaves two reasonable explanations
for what could have happened to him
the first possibility is that greyback
was simply picked up off the ground
still stunned after the battle put to
trial and sent to azkaban
and it would be in azkaban that greyback
would spend the remainder of his years
okay so that could very well be a
possibility but somehow it just doesn't
seem
right to me i can't explain why but i
think that greyback escaped
he's an elusive werewolf that lurked in
the shadows for most of his life
furthermore being a werewolf he was
particularly resilient
and would have been able to take much
more of a beating than say a normal
wizard
after the battle of hogwarts i think he
slipped away and regrouped with other
werewolves
taking a step back and biding their time
before ultimately plotting
to attack the wizarding world once again
what do you guys think
let me know in the comments section
below if you enjoy the content please
like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
you